[MUSIC PLAYING]
ASIA SEAVERS:
Rachael Ray is here.
Welcome Emmy award winning
talk show host, Rachael Ray.
Woo.
RACHAEL RAY: Hey, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
ASIA SEAVERS: Well,
hello, Rachael.
RACHAEL RAY: Well, hello.
ASIA SEAVERS: How are
you today, darling?
RACHAEL RAY: I'm good.
It's low humidity.
I like that.
ASIA SEAVERS: Great.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah, it's good.
ASIA SEAVERS: Frizz
Control yes, thank you.
So oh, wow.
I didn't know that
was reading up there.
That's awesome.
OK, cool.
RACHAEL RAY: You
don't have to read.
I answer anything.
ASIA SEAVERS: That's awesome.
Well, we have a couple
of things going on
for you in the next
couple days, couple weeks.
"Rachael Ray," your show.
RACHAEL RAY: Promises, promises.
ASIA SEAVERS: Tell
me about your show,
your 12th season coming up.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah, 12
is a big thing for me.
I got married 12 years ago.
I adopted my pit
bull 12 years ago.
We launched the
magazine 12 years ago
and the daytime talk show.
So knock on wood,
they're all still here.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
RACHAEL RAY: Going well.
ASIA SEAVERS: 12's [INAUDIBLE].
RACHAEL RAY: I remain gainfully
employed and the dog is good.
She's home with John.
It's Monday, so he's probably
having a lovely afternoon
scotch.
He usually takes Monday off, so.
ASIA SEAVERS: 12, OK,
what's your dog's name?
I do not know.
RACHAEL RAY: Isaboo.
ASIA SEAVERS:
Isaboo, oh, my gosh.
RACHAEL RAY: Isabella
is my favorite name
and I don't have time
to have human children.
And my first pit bull was
named Boo and when she passed,
I got Isaboo because
she had bindi dot
right in the middle
of her forehead
and she looked very
similar to her.
So I combined the two
names and named her Isaboo.
ASIA SEAVERS: Isaboo,
go Isaboo, whoop, whoop.
OK, what was something that
really influenced the trend
of your show, "Rachael Ray"?
RACHAEL RAY: I think
our show didn't set out
to be like anything
else of its kind.
Our show, we love
having celebrities
on but when they come on, we
like them to do a longer format
and let people get
to know them as
if they were their next
door neighbors rather
than celebrities.
So they can bring a clip of
whatever and plug whatever,
but we try and have a little
more next door neighbor
kind of time with them.
And our show is not
celebrity-dependent.
So we try and make
sure that people
see as much of
themselves on our show
as they do celebrities or
politicians or athletes
or people that they see
as celebrities or famous.
And I think that's a
fun promise, you know?
Because you never get
the same show twice.
At the very least,
hopefully, we make you hungry
and want to make dinner.
Look, the concept of the show,
the concept of our business
model as a brand is that
good life should not be
for rich or privileged people.
Life should be
adventurous and feel good
and feel fun, not just on
weekends or when you retire.
But whether it's
talking to strangers,
taking a left instead of right,
taking small vacations instead
of saving up for one big one,
making something different
for dinner, we want people
to have fun every day
they're alive.
So the show has very
small goals but we want
to reach those goals every day.
We just want people to have
fun and learn something.
Something huge?
No.
Maybe a recipe, maybe
a tip, maybe a trick,
maybe they learn something
about a celebrity
when we do have
them on that they
wouldn't see someplace else.
We like it to be a
friendly space where
everybody feels that they
can conquer what they see.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: It's another thing
that's very important to me
as a producer, a
writer, a presenter.
I want people to feel that
they have access to everything
that they see.
So we let people see
messes and successes.
We are not scripted, which is
wildly evident if you watch.
ASIA SEAVERS: That's amazing.
RACHAEL RAY: So,
you know, we want
people to feel comfortable
and not intimidated
to try anything they see.
And we want them to be a
little bit inspired to just
have a little bit more fun.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
Now, with you having
celebrities on your show,
is there a celebrity that
you've ever been starstruck
by where you're just like, oh--
RACHAEL RAY: My first crush
when I was a little girl,
and the only thing I
would put a dress on for,
was the "Tom Jones Show."
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh!
RACHAEL RAY: So the first time
Tom Jones came on the show,
I had a very difficult
time looking at him, yes.
ASIA SEAVERS: That's crazy.
I would have been
like, [GASPS] hi.
RACHAEL RAY: I mean, there's
a million huge moments.
I mean--
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: I never
thought I'd have
any sort of life in
television or hanging out
with celebrities.
So I mean, some of
my favorites are--
the most optimistic
person on the planet
to me is Michael J. Fox.
You know, the first time
he was ever on the show
overwhelmed me.
And he slow danced with me
to that song from the show
when he fell in love with
Tracy, his real-life wife.
Yeah, I know!
ASIA SEAVERS: That's amazing.
RACHAEL RAY: And he used to
get-- that guy was great.
The first day we launched
our children's initiative,
I can't believe that
was 10 years ago,
but President Clinton was there
and he partnered the Alliance
for a Healthier Generation
with our little upstart.
There's a lot of
important days on my show.
ASIA SEAVERS: That's good.
RACHAEL RAY: You know,
I think every day,
as I said, what's most important
to me is that-- every day,
we shoot three shows on
most days, taping our show.
What's important to
me is that I'm always
surprised by how
many shows don't have
a celebrity or a star
athlete or a politician
and then when you're like, wow,
the audience really loved that.
And it's just people watching
each other and sharing ideas
with each other.
Those are some of my favorites
from that arena of my life.
ASIA SEAVERS: Now, with
the clip we just watched,
it seems like you have
so much fun on set.
What is the funniest
thing that's
ever happened to you on set?
RACHAEL RAY: I mean, it
depends, know what I mean?
It's all funny, you know?
When Regis sets himself
on fire, it's funny.
When I cut myself
on air, it's usually
pretty funny for people.
I mean, we just--
I just like that people see
that, we don't clean things up
or--
what I'm upset about is
how much we over edit.
We take out-- when Denis Leary
and I are sitting together,
there's a lot of heavy
editing that goes down.
But it's more because of
our language with each other
than the content.
But, you know, I don't know.
I think we always have,
hopefully, a good time.
Every day should be
fun for everybody.
ASIA SEAVERS: That's so good.
Now, with your first--
I remember watching "Rachael
Ray" a while back and it
was cooking, cooking,
cooking, cooking, cooking,
and so much cooking and--
RACHAEL RAY: Well,
I was on 30 minute--
I've been on Food Network
for 20 years, 19 years, so--
ASIA SEAVERS: That's amazing.
RACHAEL RAY: --yeah, of course.
ASIA SEAVERS: Now,
was the transition
tough to come from cooking
shows to doing interviews?
RACHAEL RAY: No, it
wasn't my idea at all.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh.
RACHAEL RAY: My
friend, Brooke Johnson,
who ran a Food
Network at the time,
she said, you know, you
should do a talk show.
I said, well, I'm under
contract with you guys.
It's not, you know--
ASIA SEAVERS: You
got to figure it out.
RACHAEL RAY: Uh, no.
So we've always been partners
with Scripps and CBS,
of course, and our
little company.
And then Oprah became
a part of the process
and invited me on her show.
And I mean, once
you're on Oprah--
ASIA SEAVERS: You're there.
RACHAEL RAY: --you're in.
ASIA SEAVERS: You're in there.
RACHAEL RAY: You
know, so it was just
a weird set of circumstances.
It wasn't part of the plan.
It just sort of
organically happened.
ASIA SEAVERS: Now, you
have another show coming up
that's premiered, "Worst
Cooks in America."
RACHAEL RAY: Oh, that's work
that I do for Food Network
and I do that project especially
for my friend, Anne Burrell.
I love Anne, so I'm kind of
a sucker for any friend who
says, please come do this.
That is a very hard show to do.
Yeah, it's been on
all summer, I think.
It's probably coming towards
the end of its cycle.
But "Worst Cooks" really
is one of the worst jobs
to have because the
days are so long
and you really
torture these people
and they really do
suck in the kitchen.
So it's hard.
It's like watching children
play in traffic, you know?
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh, no.
RACHAEL RAY: It's
like, here's people
who don't know how
to turn on stoves
and they're playing
with knives and fire.
And you know--
ASIA SEAVERS: And the
model for that is people
bring in their dishes.
And do try the dishes?
Do you taste the dishes?
RACHAEL RAY: Oh,
we're supposed to.
But since I work very
little for Food Network,
I feel perfectly free to
say, I'm not eating that.
ASIA SEAVERS: No,
this is not OK.
RACHAEL RAY: And
it is Anne's show.
Anne's kind of the same.
Anne's like, yeah,
I'm not going there.
The worst of the
worst that we ever had
was a very sweet man, older man
trying to learn a new trick.
That's great.
He cooked for us
and he put together
a jar of mayonnaise, three
or four cans of tuna,
and a jar of raspberry
preserves and then baked it
with American cheese
slices on top.
ASIA SEAVERS: No.
No.
RACHAEL RAY: In a loaf pan.
ASIA SEAVERS: No.
RACHAEL RAY: There's no
freaking way I'm eating that.
I mean, of course not.
ASIA SEAVERS: Does anyone
actually try them, though?
Do people actually--
RACHAEL RAY: Oh,
Anne and I try a lot.
We've had a lot of really
horrible, awful stuff.
But you know,
everybody's heart is
in the right place
and the reason
I do this show is that
it's very important to Anne
to really teach people and
get them excited about it.
And the reason I do it is
not only because of Anne
but because I think it changes
the quality of your life
to be able to provide food
for yourself and people
that you care about,
whether you're
a rocket scientist or
you cook for a living.
It changes the day-to-day
quality of your life.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah,
that's very true.
And even what you said about
cooking for people you love.
You have a pet food line.
RACHAEL RAY: I started that
because several years ago,
a lot of American
animals, dogs and cats,
were literally being poisoned
by their loved ones unknowingly
and unwittingly
because there were so
many fillers in the foods
that were being imported
and there was no
regulation of it.
We've always had, since day
one of the magazine, a pet food
column if you want to cook
something for your animal.
But to be honest,
it's hard for people
to find time to
cook for themselves.
It's not realistic people are
going to cook for their pets
every single day.
So we started a line
with an American company.
At the time, it
was called Dad's.
Ainsworth is the
name of the company.
And they were lovely
people and they
agreed to make this
food, two recipes based
on what I would write
for the magazine,
and to the highest of standards.
I have eaten the kibble and
the cat food, wet cat food.
Needs a little salt
but it's tasty.
But I eat it on
television all the time
to prove to people
that it's delicious--
ASIA SEAVERS: Edible.
RACHAEL RAY: --and I can,
of course that it's tasty.
But because that brand's
been very successful,
we've raised and
given away I think
we may be over $17 million now.
Because we were at $16 million.
And then we gave $1
million to Harvey,
to animal victims of that--
ASIA SEAVERS: Hurricane.
RACHAEL RAY: --tragedy.
So I think now we're
over $17 million.
But it's because the
brand is successful
and it's doing well for animals
that have special allergies,
elderly dogs.
We've really had great
luck with that brand
and it serves its purpose.
One of the most
important lessons
I think I learned over the
last 19 years of my life
and building this brand
and building the business
is you can make business models
to fund anything you want.
It shouldn't just be about
what you can collect and get.
If you become
successful in business,
you can make a model,
large or small,
to fund whatever you want.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: So we
send kids to school.
We improve school food.
We feed hungry
American children,
that was our first
initiative Yum-O.
We used that as the
model for Nutrish.
That's how we fund
animals, animal rescue.
And we don't just
save dogs and cats.
We save horses and
llamas and goats
and all kinds of non-kill
facilities, large and small.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh,
that's so amazing.
Entering the pet
food market, what
was probably the
most surprising thing
to learn about the
actual pet food market?
RACHAEL RAY: Nothing, really.
I mean, once you give people a
fair price and a great product,
it's a--
you know, I never look
at business like that.
I try and think of what I
want in a product or a thing.
I design furniture.
I design pots.
I certainly produce
and program television.
I write recipes, religiously,
tons of them every single day.
And I try and figure out
how to serve my customer
and what's not being done yet.
I never think about,
what do I have to learn
about this genre or that genre.
I try and come up with,
as a consumer or customer
myself, what do I think's
missing out there.
And that's my head space.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: I don't study
what the other guy's doing.
I don't really care.
I wish them all the
success in the world.
I want to come up with something
that feels comfortable for me
and the people I work with
and our style and our way.
And if that doesn't work,
we move along and came up
with the new solution.
And if it does work, great.
We try and nurture that
thing and let it grow.
We are not a group
of people that
goes to work thinking about the
next guy or the competition.
We go to work to problem solve
and to work for each other,
to give each other
something that's
a solution for a small problem.
ASIA SEAVERS: Wow.
Now, have you ever
cooked for your pets?
Do you make dinner
for your pets often?
RACHAEL RAY: Always.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh, how often?
Always, every day.
I mean, Izzy also
likes her dry food
and there's always some
kibble in the bowl.
But Izzy's a very weird dog.
She only eats when she's
truly, truly hungry.
I can't tell you how many times
my husband comes home from--
he does these dinners with
his friends once every month
or every other month,
steak and men night.
It's mostly scotch
and men night but they
eat a little bit of
steak and he brings home
Peter Luger or something.
She will walk away from it.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh.
RACHAEL RAY: If
she's not hungry,
she doesn't want any part of it.
ASIA SEAVERS: It's a good--
RACHAEL RAY: She's a very,
very, very, very picky dog,
very picky eater.
But yeah, I cook for
her all the time.
I love to cook.
ASIA SEAVERS: That's amazing.
When I think about pet
food, I'm like, oh, my gosh,
if I don't eat it then
why should my pet eat it?
And that's literally what--
RACHAEL RAY: Well
that's the point--
ASIA SEAVERS: --your brand is.
RACHAEL RAY: --behind our food.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: Exactly.
If I wouldn't feed
it to people, why
would I give it to someone--
ASIA SEAVERS: Exactly.
RACHAEL RAY: --or to something
that's as important in my life
as humans?
ASIA SEAVERS: Exactly.
Now, with the whole Google
food module-- as you know,
Google is a tech
company, whoop, whoop.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah, but
you also got a lot of food
in this place.
ASIA SEAVERS: Exactly.
RACHAEL RAY: In
this one building,
y'all have eight restaurants.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yes, exactly.
So what do you
think the next food
trend is with technology
and food merging together?
RACHAEL RAY: You know, I think
that food, as in everything,
because of Google, access to
information, because of the way
people are so connected
now and anyone can go up
on YouTube and share
stop motion quick videos
and how they made this
or that and people
are educating themselves in what
they eat and why they eat it
and how they eat it, I
think that it opens up
lots of doors and
possibilities for everyone,
for people just starting
out in the business,
for people that want to continue
to educate themselves or build
their customer base.
I think it's great.
I mean, people ask
me all the time,
what do you think about the meal
kits and the meal deliveries?
I'm like, listen, anything
gets you into the kitchen,
sooner or later, I
hope you'll learn
how to do it for yourself,
because it of course
costs you less money and
you have the byproduct.
You don't have to cook out
of these little pouches
and they send you
three pea pods.
But I think it's
terrific if people
need that as the thing that gets
them started or down that line.
I think it's great.
ASIA SEAVERS: Do you see your
self in the mobile applications
market?
We have so many markets--
RACHAEL RAY: Only as much as I
see the smart people around me
trying to push me into that.
I mean, is it something
that I'm naturally good at?
No.
Do we have a lot of really
educated people around me
that will bring us there?
Sure, I hope.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
Now, how do you find the
balance between eating
healthy and just comfort food?
I love comfort food.
You love comfort food.
RACHAEL RAY: That
one drives me nuts.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right?
RACHAEL RAY: I think that
word is such bullshit.
I just do.
I am not a person that likes
to live balanced anything.
I eat colorful food.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yes.
RACHAEL RAY: I cook
with largely olive oil.
I've never felt
guilt about food.
I am not--
I eat what I feel like eating.
But actually, most people that
cook for a living or that work
in the service industry,
what makes us happy
is to make the person
we're serving happy.
So all we want to cook is
whatever the person sitting
with us wants to eat.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
RACHAEL RAY: We're
not picky at all.
We'll literally eat anything.
When I was a kid
and Judy Blume had
the book "How to
Eat Fried Worms,"
I was the kid that would
eat the worm for $1.
ASIA SEAVERS: What?
RACHAEL RAY: I really
can eat anything.
I'm happy with just
scrambled eggs.
But it's not something I
give, really, a thought to.
And I never give a thought
to balance about my life.
I can cook all day and do three
shows and get home at 8:00.
We always make dinner.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: I
prefer to be at home.
I prefer to go there, put my
Spamalot slippers and Jets
slippers on, get in the
kitchen, open some wine,
and make our dinner.
And that's the way I was raised.
My mother worked 80
to 100 hours a week.
My grandfather before her was
my best friend when I was a kid.
He worked 100 hours a week.
He'd get his kids out of bed
in the middle of the night
so he could sing
arias to them they
could watch the northern lights.
It's about your quality of life.
It's not about balance.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: That word
kind of is like getting hit
with a shock or something.
It shouldn't be about balance.
If you love your
job, you should love
doing it a lot of the time.
If you care about enjoying
the time you're home,
you should care enough to
stay up a little later,
pull out a pan, make
some food for yourself
because it feeds your soul,
not just your stomach.
It's more about the quality
for me than the balance thing.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
Now, with the quality, I
know that your shopping list
is probably insane every week.
[LAUGHS] Sorry.
RACHAEL RAY: This is such--
people find this
so freaky about me.
ASIA SEAVERS: Uh-huh.
RACHAEL RAY: My friend Emily
made me this wrapping paper
of all of my grocery lists.
She went in and--
ASIA SEAVERS: What?
RACHAEL RAY: --photographed
them because she
thinks they're so nuts.
And now whenever I
give a gift to someone,
I don't even have
to put a card on it
because they know because it's
wrapped in my grocery lists.
Yeah, I'm a nutty,
nutty list maker.
I don't know if I believe
in horoscopes or whatever,
but I am a Virgo and
that's supposed to be
people love to make lists.
ASIA SEAVERS: Virgos.
RACHAEL RAY: And I'm--
ASIA SEAVERS: A listed out--
RACHAEL RAY: I'm nuts.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah.
So every year, we take--
a group of our friends,
primarily musicians and cooks,
we did, for 10 years,
take 100 people every year
to the scene of the crime
where my husband and I got
married in Italy.
It's the only ridiculous
expenditure in my life,
otherwise I live in sweatpants
and I'm down at the "Tar-jay."
but we would, every
year for 10 years,
take all of our friends and most
of our family to Italy with us
and just party for the
whole weekend, right?
ASIA SEAVERS: I'm
now your family.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah.
Now, that castle, the guy who
owns it, he moved back in.
So now it's a much
smaller thing.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: And we have
like 30, 35 of us go to Italy
and they're all
cooks or musicians.
And I go there and I cook
for two of the nights.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: And our friends
jump in and make extra dishes
to go on the table.
But I basically just live in the
kitchen for all of it, right?
So the list I just finished--
this is coming up next week--
the list I just finished
over this weekend,
it is 16 handwritten pages
of equipment, the groceries,
every single checklist
of everything possible.
It's 16 pages.
ASIA SEAVERS: What?
RACHAEL RAY: [LAUGHS]
I took a photograph
and sent it to Italy.
I call my friend
Giancarlo at the place.
I'm like, are you ready?
Let's go through the list.
ASIA SEAVERS: We're
going to do it.
RACHAEL RAY: And she's
like, oh, my god.
Yeah, 2 and 1/2 hours on
the phone to go through it.
Yeah, I'm a nutter.
And then I get there and
of course I change my mind
when I get to the market or
I see this or I see that.
But I do that for my
family every week.
I cook for my mom.
Usually every other
weekend we go upstate.
I'm from the Adirondacks.
And I try and plan out
every menu seasonally.
I'll get up before work and go
to Union Square Greenmarket.
What I can't find, I'll
order through the kitchens
at the show or my
husband will go
to Garden of Eden or something.
But--
ASIA SEAVERS: So that's
the 16-page game plan.
You're like, divvy it up.
RACHAEL RAY: Next
week is 16 to pages.
Usually for the weekend,
it's only two to four.
ASIA SEAVERS: What?
So what is your game plan when
you go in the grocery store?
Is it like produce
last, this first--
RACHAEL RAY: Well, I rarely
go to grocery store or grocery
stores.
I go to-- I'm very lucky in
that when I'm in the city,
I go to Union Square Greenmarket
for most of the season.
And then I can also
order stuff at the show
and tack it into orders
that are coming in, right?
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: And I love
to shop in Chelsea Market.
There's a lobster place
and Buon Italia, I love.
So I kind of piecemeal it and
I put together my game plan.
But then when I
get to the market,
I also say, oh, yeah, we should
do a whole roast cauliflower,
too.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh.
RACHAEL RAY: I have
a thumbnail sketch,
but when I get there,
I mean, generally, I
cook like every person
who cooks for a living.
You cook seasonally and what
you know is going to be there
and what's going to look
good and have the best price.
But you always change it up a
little bit or mystery box it
when you get there.
If I was teaching people how
to shop, which I do often
on our show, you
go into the store,
you should always take a
look at the loss leaders.
There's a loss leader
in every department.
Buy that, whatever
it is, even if you
don't want to get that week.
Put it in your freezer.
Always shop low and high,
never in the middle.
Those are the best prices.
Always buy per unit of
measure, not the price that's
ticketed on the item,
so on and so forth.
ASIA SEAVERS: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
You just saved so
much of my life
right now because I'm just
like, middle aisle, whatever
I can reach, I'm just like,
OK, you go in the cart.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah, you're
wasting a lot of money.
ASIA SEAVERS: Apparently.
RACHAEL RAY: And
you got to learn
how to break down a chicken.
You've got to learn how to buy--
ASIA SEAVERS: My mom
taught me that last week.
She's like, we're doing this.
RACHAEL RAY: You've
got to learn it.
ASIA SEAVERS: You want gloves?
RACHAEL RAY: If you know
how to break down a chicken,
you know a lot.
ASIA SEAVERS: Thank you.
RACHAEL RAY: And it
saves you a lot of money.
ASIA SEAVERS: A
lot of-- it does.
RACHAEL RAY: A lot of money.
ASIA SEAVERS: And
then you can freeze it
and just have it for next--
RACHAEL RAY: That's right.
ASIA SEAVERS: I was
like, thanks, Mom.
RACHAEL RAY: I know.
ASIA SEAVERS: Make
it [INAUDIBLE]
RACHAEL RAY: Isn't that fun?
ASIA SEAVERS: It's so great.
Oh, my gosh.
Now, what influenced
all of this?
What inspired you to get into
cooking and start teaching?
RACHAEL RAY: I mean,
just luck of the draw.
My mother is one of 10 children.
My grandfather was one of 16.
14 lived.
The four youngest came here.
My mother was his
firstborn so she was always
in the kitchen with my grandpa.
My grandpa was my best
friend when I was little.
My mom worked in
restaurants for 55 years.
And she didn't trust other
people to watch her children,
so we were largely with her.
All of us learned how to cook.
I have one brother, one sister.
I think because my mom was one
of 10, she stopped at three.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh.
RACHAEL RAY: But it
just felt good to me.
I like working in food.
It's easy.
You're always going
to have a gig.
People will always be hungry.
ASIA SEAVERS: Hungry.
RACHAEL RAY: You
know what I mean?
ASIA SEAVERS: Always.
RACHAEL RAY: The rest of
it was ice cream or whipped
cream on the cake.
I don't eat sweets
but, you know,
extra cheese on the spaghetti
was the other stuff.
But I like working in food.
There's great job security.
It's very humbling and
empowering at the same time.
I think everybody should
have to work in food.
I don't care what you do.
ASIA SEAVERS: It's
a good experience.
It's a humbling experience.
RACHAEL RAY: Sure is.
ASIA SEAVERS: It
teaches you a lot.
And you will never--
RACHAEL RAY: Dish
machine operator
will teach you a whole lot.
ASIA SEAVERS: You were
a dish machine operator?
RACHAEL RAY: Hell
yes, my first job.
That's glamorous.
ASIA SEAVERS: It is.
It's fun.
I think it would be fun.
RACHAEL RAY: Oh, no,
it's not fun, sweetheart.
ASIA SEAVERS: It's
hot, it's crazy.
RACHAEL RAY: It's 120 degrees--
ASIA SEAVERS: No.
RACHAEL RAY: --all
day and you're
one big sweaty nasty
piece of business.
And at 14 or 15, that ain't fun.
ASIA SEAVERS: It is not.
RACHAEL RAY: That
ain't a cute look.
ASIA SEAVERS: No, what is your
personal mission after you've
got the luck of the draw,
you got through here,
you've come up with these
different innovative ideas
and cookware, cookbooks,
what is your next--
RACHAEL RAY:
Furniture, too, yeah.
ASIA SEAVERS: Furniture.
RACHAEL RAY: I love
designing furniture.
It's fun.
Just to stay true to the brand.
You can't be all
things to all people.
You have to decide what you are
and who you are and work with
and surround yourself
with people that
are of like thinking, believe
in whatever your mantra
or motto is.
And then just be grateful.
I like the feeling of
working as hard as possible.
I like feeling that
I put in a full day.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: Whether
it's a day off or not,
I have to be active, you know?
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: And as long as
I'm true to that, I'm good.
ASIA SEAVERS: That makes sense.
To stay stagnant,
it's like, what am I--
I think it's a Virgo thing.
We're just like, we cannot--
RACHAEL RAY: No,
I can't do that.
I'm real bad at it.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
You have to keep--
RACHAEL RAY: And
my husband's a Leo
but he's a cusp-y
kind of a thing.
Our birthdays are just a few
days apart and he's the same.
We suck at doing nothing.
It's really bad.
He has to be in his studio
or I'm in the kitchen.
And we have to be
working during the day.
We're not good at just
being like, hey, let's
watch nine movies in a row.
ASIA SEAVERS: No.
RACHAEL RAY: Although
that does happen.
"Ozark" really--
[LAUGHTER]
I was like, oh, this is bad.
ASIA SEAVERS: If it's good--
RACHAEL RAY: I watched the
entire thing in 30 hours.
I'm like, I might have an issue.
ASIA SEAVERS: Binge
watching Netflix and chill.
RACHAEL RAY: Mm-hmm.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh, yes.
Now, what is--
RACHAEL RAY: Or Apple or Amazon.
I've been known to
do it on all of them.
ASIA SEAVERS: All of them.
RACHAEL RAY: I know.
It's dangerous.
That is dangerous.
ASIA SEAVERS: It is.
The on-demand TV
is really just--
RACHAEL RAY: It is
really dangerous.
ASIA SEAVERS: --devouring time.
I'm like, yes, now.
Now, what is the most
interesting thing
we would learn from you
without watching your movie--
watching your TV show,
books, or anything like that?
What's the most interesting
thing we could--
RACHAEL RAY: I don't know.
I wait on people for a living.
You can't ask somebody that does
what I do for a living, what's
the coolest thing about you?
I don't know.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
I think that it's
pretty cool, everything
you're doing thus far, though.
It's pretty awesome.
RACHAEL RAY: I mean, I like
to jump out of airplanes.
That's fun.
ASIA SEAVERS: That is--
what?
OK.
RACHAEL RAY: Love it.
ASIA SEAVERS: How
many times have you
jumped out of an airplane?
RACHAEL RAY: Four or five.
ASIA SEAVERS: Where, were they--
RACHAEL RAY: And I've been
shut down a couple times,
because of winds or whatever.
But yeah, I love it.
I mean, it organizes my
brain in a strange way.
It makes me very calm
for a few months.
I love it.
ASIA SEAVERS: Were they
all different heights
are the same like--
RACHAEL RAY: No, the flight
deck that we jump from,
the sky ranch is 14,500.
So it's like three miles.
It's fun.
It really is wildly
relaxing, I swear.
ASIA SEAVERS: Did anyone else
hear three miles just out
of the sky, just pew.
RACHAEL RAY: You know
what's so funny is
I am petrified of being
on a ladder over six feet.
Short heights, I'm terrible at.
ASIA SEAVERS: No.
RACHAEL RAY: Jumping out
of an airplane, love it.
ASIA SEAVERS: You
have time to think.
RACHAEL RAY: Can't
get there fast enough.
I love it.
Oh, so fun.
ASIA SEAVERS: I wanted to
go indoor skydiving just
to be like, OK.
RACHAEL RAY: That was harder.
ASIA SEAVERS: What?
RACHAEL RAY: I just
did that with friends.
My girlfriends and I
were up in Montreal
and we did one of
those tube things
because it looks like so fun
and I'm like, ah, I got this.
ASIA SEAVERS: Your
face is just like--
RACHAEL RAY: Oh, it's horrible.
It was so much more fun
jumping out of the real plane.
ASIA SEAVERS: Real airplane, no.
Nuh-uh.
I'm like, there's a ground.
I might hit it
and I'm just flat.
But at least there's air.
You can slow down.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah, no, actually,
once you open the chute,
it's so incredibly chill.
You can totally stop your
body if you push down
with both hands
at the same time.
And you're just suspended
above the earth.
You're not dropping at
all for several seconds.
You're just there
and it's pin silent.
It's so cool.
It's very cool.
That tube thing, not so cool.
ASIA SEAVERS: It was just loud.
RACHAEL RAY: Just looking
like bug or something
in a hair dryer.
It was really bad.
ASIA SEAVERS: Is it
hot air, cold air?
RACHAEL RAY: No,
it's just like--
ASIA SEAVERS: Regular air.
RACHAEL RAY: Right,
room temperature air.
But I don't know.
I sucked at it.
I was just getting
batted around.
ASIA SEAVERS: I'm taking my--
RACHAEL RAY: Like
something got sucked up
in the vacuum cleaner.
I felt like I was in a Dyson.
[LAUGHTER]
ASIA SEAVERS: This is
what the dust feels like.
RACHAEL RAY: No, it was--
ASIA SEAVERS: Just freaking out.
RACHAEL RAY: --not cool.
It wasn't good.
I think I need a lot more
practice time in those tubes.
I did not do a respectable job.
ASIA SEAVERS: All the tricks.
Have you mastered any
tricks going airborne?
RACHAEL RAY: I love
doing tricks but it's
easy to do tricks when
you jump out of planes
because you can't go by yourself
till after you go four times.
So they do whatever you want.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: So
my guy that I love
to go with, he's been
over 10,000 times.
So he would spin us and flip us
and do all that kind of stuff.
ASIA SEAVERS: That makes sense.
RACHAEL RAY: Yep.
That's what I love about it.
Because you can be like Iron
Man for a couple of seconds.
ASIA SEAVERS: I love Iron Man.
RACHAEL RAY: I know, me, too.
ASIA SEAVERS: I'm like,
I need to do this.
No.
RACHAEL RAY: I so
wish I had the ability
to be an actress
because I really
want to do those action movies.
I want to shoot guns, kill
people, jump off stuff.
ASIA SEAVERS: No stunt
double, just straight up--
RACHAEL RAY: No,
that's the fun part.
ASIA SEAVERS: No,
I would be afraid.
I'm like, no--
RACHAEL RAY: No, not me.
ASIA SEAVERS: --don't hit me.
RACHAEL RAY: That look like--
ASIA SEAVERS: Don't it.
RACHAEL RAY: --so much fun.
I just want to get in the there.
ASIA SEAVERS: Flipping out cars.
"Fast and Furious," you're next.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah.
Well, no, not with the cars
so much, more hand-to-hand.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
All right, "Mission Impossible."
RACHAEL RAY: It's weird.
ASIA SEAVERS: There we go.
RACHAEL RAY: A lot of people
think of them as nightmares
but I have dreams where I'm
like in bar brawls and stuff
and I'm a bad ass.
That, to me, is super fun
and I wake up all excited.
ASIA SEAVERS: Did you know what
my dream was about last night?
Do you write your dreams down?
RACHAEL RAY: No.
ASIA SEAVERS: No?
I do have notebooks everywhere.
Everything that I do, whether
it's a piece of furniture,
a recipe, every single
thing I make in my home,
I have over 20
years of notebooks.
Every single cookbook,
everything that I
do, I write in notebooks.
I do have a notebook
next to my bed,
but I don't write down dreams.
I rarely even remember them.
I do write down recipes
in the middle of the night
or if I come up with an idea
for a different shape of pillow
or a different type of
end table or something
or a different shape of
pop we haven't done yet,
I do keep the notebook
there for that.
ASIA SEAVERS:
Rachael Ray library.
RACHAEL RAY: That's
creepy, but--
[LAUGHTER]
ASIA SEAVERS: I was thinking--
RACHAEL RAY: And they're all
just those regular composition
books.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
Oh, that's amazing.
RACHAEL RAY: I have a
whole cellar full of them.
ASIA SEAVERS: Is there a food
that you absolutely hate?
You talked about
food that you love--
RACHAEL RAY: Not hate.
Again, I think that if
you're blessed enough not
to be going hungry--
I mean, I would literally
eat anything and I have.
I have, literally, probably
eaten everything there is.
ASIA SEAVERS: What's the
craziest thing you've eaten?
RACHAEL RAY: I mean,
I've eaten everything.
I've eaten every organ
in animals' bodies.
I've eaten bugs and
all that kind of stuff.
Things I don't really love--
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: --I don't like the
mouth feel of cooked salmon.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: Not
really my thing.
But I love smoked
salmon and every type
of sashimi and sushi.
But I don't love cooked salmon.
Kind of meh.
And I don't like store
bought mayonnaise
because I didn't
grow up with it.
I make aioli and I am
obsessed with Fabanaise,
the egg-less mayonnaise.
Love the consistency of
it, use it all the time.
It's fabulous.
But I just didn't
grow up with it.
So I'm not the first one in
line at the mayo bar, [LAUGHS]
at the condiment station at
wherever But there's really
nothing I wouldn't eat or try.
ASIA SEAVERS: Now, what is your
favorite, absolute favorite
food that you could--
RACHAEL RAY: Don't have one.
ASIA SEAVERS: [GASPS]
RACHAEL RAY: Seriously don't.
I mean, I love pasta.
I love primarily
Mediterranean food.
But again, I'm not picky.
If I haven't had a really great
scrambled egg or an omelet
in a while and I make
an omelet that I'm like,
oh, that's really good.
That's the best
thing I ever had.
Do you know what I mean?
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
RACHAEL RAY: I think a lot of
people that cook for a living
are like that.
We're just not picky.
ASIA SEAVERS: We just like food.
I love food.
Now, there are
preferences though.
Kale versus broccoli, which one?
RACHAEL RAY: They're both
cruciferous vegetables.
I like them both.
I like-- I don't
love a kale salad
unless it can set for a while
and start to get and proper
and have a good chew to it.
But I liked kale
before kale was cool.
My grandpa grew kale
when I was this big.
So I was a kid that nobody
wanted to sit next to
in kindergarten or first
grade because my lunch stank.
Sardines sandwiches
with onions and--
ASIA SEAVERS: Perfect.
RACHAEL RAY: --pickled kale
or pickled garden vegetables
and a big old sardine
sandwich was my life.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
So what did you have--
RACHAEL RAY: I was not
it is especially popular
super young kid.
ASIA SEAVERS: Just in the
lunchroom opening up sardines,
hey, you want to trade?
No.
RACHAEL RAY: No.
Nope.
Trade?
Nobody would even sit
at the table, man.
No.
ASIA SEAVERS: I like any food
that makes your breath stink.
I love anchovies,
olives, onions.
RACHAEL RAY: We have
a lot in common.
ASIA SEAVERS: They're
just like, mm, yes.
RACHAEL RAY: Yes.
ASIA SEAVERS: They nurture the--
RACHAEL RAY: Down
with the anchovies.
ASIA SEAVERS: Always.
OK, we have a speed round.
Are you ready for
the speed round?
RACHAEL RAY: You'll be
surprised at how bad I
am at speed rounds.
ASIA SEAVERS: What?
RACHAEL RAY: No, I'm too wordy.
I talk too much.
And there's always
a but, but whatever.
I'll try.
I'll do my best.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
So I know that you like all
foods but you have to pick, OK?
You have to choose.
RACHAEL RAY: No, I'm not
going to play your game.
ASIA SEAVERS: You-- no.
RACHAEL RAY: I'm not
going to play your game.
ASIA SEAVERS: No, Rachael--
RACHAEL RAY: I have
a friend, Melanie--
see, here we go.
Now here's a really long story.
ASIA SEAVERS: Go for it.
RACHAEL RAY: Melanie is
a famous photographer
and she does this series
of books, "The Last Meal"
or "The Last Supper."
It's all these chefs
and what they'd eat.
And she asked me
to do the first one
and I said, oh, that
makes me so creeped out.
I don't want to do it.
I ended up in the
sequel to that book.
And the only way I could
do it was to say the truth.
If I knew it was my
last meal, I wouldn't
be worried about eating.
I'd be doing some serious
drugs or drinking.
I'd be really bummed out.
ASIA SEAVERS: That's true.
RACHAEL RAY: But I would
want my first meal,
if there was an
afterlife in some form
to be with my grandfather
and my first dog.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: Boo loved
butternut squash more
than anything in the world.
So it would be butternut
squash for Boo.
And my grandpa and I loved
sardines and anchovies.
So we'd have spaghetti
with sardines or anchovies
and a side of roast
squash, and I'd
be eating with the Runzo
boys, my grandpa's best
friends and my grandpa
and my first pit bull.
That's who I'd be eating with.
That's as close as
you're going to get.
ASIA SEAVERS: Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Now, you cook a lot.
Do you ever go out on
the town, and if you
do, what is one of your
top favorite restaurants?
RACHAEL RAY:
RACHAEL RAY: I'd like to go out
when we're taking friends out
or if I have friends
visiting and they don't get
to go out in New York a lot.
I like a lot of places.
You have to pick a category.
I love Madame Vo
for Vietnamese food.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: I mean, it depends.
I live Via Carota if I'm going
to have Italian food that I
didn't make myself.
I love Via Carota.
Pizza, we like Speedy Romeo
and Motorino and Mexican food,
I like Toro Blanco,
Josh Capon's place.
It depends on what it is.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: If
it's Chinese food,
I like this Australian
Chinese restaurant.
[INAUDIBLE],, what
is the name of that?
AUDIENCE: Chinese Tuxedo.
RACHAEL RAY: Yes,
Chinese Tuxedo.
Love that place.
Very sexy.
You know, it
depends on the food.
I have a place I like to go
to for pretty much anything.
Sure, I live in New York.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
It's a big city.
Now, you have to
ask this question.
What would you do without EVOO?
RACHAEL RAY: I guess
I'd use canola oil.
ASIA SEAVERS: No!
RACHAEL RAY: I mean, what--
if it didn't exist, that's
your choice I guess.
Avocado oil?
I don't know.
I mean, I only use olive
oil because that's--
my grandpa is an
Italian-American immigrant
and that's the fat
we cooked with.
It's not like I'm an oil hater.
But that's what we always have
in the pantry because that's
how I was raised.
ASIA SEAVERS: I can't
imagine my life without EVOO.
I'm like, I can't--
RACHAEL RAY: No, I think it
gives you a nice shiny coat.
My mom always rubbed it on
her feet, warm, on her feet
and in her hair.
Maybe too much
information, but you know.
We use it for everything.
[LAUGHS]
ASIA SEAVERS: Well, thank
you so much, Rachael.
RACHAEL RAY: That was easy.
ASIA SEAVERS: It was a pleasure.
RACHAEL RAY: That was fun.
ASIA SEAVERS: It was.
I'm not like, [GROWLS].
No, no?
Was I scary?
RACHAEL RAY: No, you're
not scary at all.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yay!
Whoop, whoop.
So what we're going to do now
is open the questioning up
to the audience.
There's a mic to my left
and a mic to my right.
If you would like to
line up behind that,
go ahead and give Rachael--
RACHAEL RAY: Oh, such a rush.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right?
[LAUGHTER]
No, really.
Be my guest.
Go for it.
RACHAEL RAY: I answer anything.
Have fun with it.
AUDIENCE: I'm right near the
mic so I figured I should--
RACHAEL RAY: Oh, you
have a nice voice.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RACHAEL RAY: Voice envy.
AUDIENCE: I'm a yoga
teacher on the side, so--
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Lots of practice.
RACHAEL RAY: Lots of
controlled breathing.
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
So you're very
humble and talking
about the beginning of your
career, you just got lucky.
I'm actually curious to
know, obviously a lot of us
you work for Google,
probably very goal oriented,
had an idea in mind
kind of before we
got into this whole gig.
RACHAEL RAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And it sounds like you
are very entrepreneurial right
from the beginning.
RACHAEL RAY: I am
very entrepreneurial
and I like the idea
of being fearless.
I think if you can
close your eyes
and see yourself
trying something,
that that's something
you should then try.
When I was a little kid, I
started a basket company,
when delicious Liaisons--
I mean, when "Dangerous
Liasons" was a movie.
I started a little
basket company,
hand drew the whole catalog.
It was called Delicious Liasons.
I only sold 45 baskets.
This was not a big industry.
But I thought that would be fun.
And I just liked the name
in my head so I did it.
I think that it's
good to be fearless
and that you do need to be
able to picture yourself trying
something.
But my mom taught
me a great lesson.
Always work harder
than everybody else
and be grateful for that job
and you'll get opportunity.
And of the opportunities
that present themselves,
if you can close your eyes
and see yourself trying it,
what's the worst thing
that could happen?
You go back to the thing you
were already grateful for.
That's why you have to start
with gratitude and working
harder.
If you can work harder than
anybody else and be grateful,
you can be literally fearless.
It's like jumping
out of an airplane
because the only
thing that can happen
is you go back to what
you were doing before.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: So I truly believe
that's the key to my life.
And going to bed feeling
good and getting out of bed
feeling good is that
if the worst thing that
can happen to you is what
you were doing last month,
last year, last week,
then you can try anything.
AUDIENCE: You'd be a
great yoga teacher.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHAEL RAY: I
think I'm too loud.
A friend of mine has a yoga
studio and she's really cool
and I'm always so scared
to go there because I
don't want to embarrass her.
I don't want to be the
person that goes, ha!
You know?
Or somebody falls over
and I accidentally laugh.
Or I pass some gross gas
or weird burp or something.
ASIA SEAVERS: That is
me in the yoga studio.
RACHAEL RAY: I always
pictured myself--
that is something I'm
really phobic about.
I really want to try yoga.
I was a cheerleader.
I'm very bendy, stretchy.
I think I'd be
good at it, but I'm
petrified to go because
I think I'm too loud.
ASIA SEAVERS: I am loud in yoga.
RACHAEL RAY: I'm also scared
to go to really, really
fine restaurants.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: When you get up the
Michelin star scale, petrified.
ASIA SEAVERS: Yep.
RACHAEL RAY: Because I just
feel like I'm not in that club.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
RACHAEL RAY: You know?
Somehow, I start to sweat
when I walk through the door.
ASIA SEAVERS: Am I
doing this right?
RACHAEL RAY: Like they're
going to come from me mid-meal
and say, excuse me, Miss Ray,
but you're really just not
our client here.
[LAUGHS]
ASIA SEAVERS: Am I
using the right fork?
RACHAEL RAY: It's the truth.
ASIA SEAVERS: What is going on?
Every once in
awhile, I get invited
to those types of places
and I'm always petrified.
And I'm not hungry
because I'm so nervous.
I don't want to eat anything.
So then it looks like I'm
rude and inappropriate.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh.
You've got to get a
side salad, something.
Just--
RACHAEL RAY: I know.
ASIA SEAVERS: --one time.
I need therapy, if
one only had the time.
[LAUGHS]
ASIA SEAVERS: Any
other questions?
Next question.
Hey, go for it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Rachael.
Shameless plug, I was
on your show twice.
RACHAEL RAY: Woo-hoo!
Did you have fun?
AUDIENCE: I had an amazing time.
The first time, I asked
Mario Lopez on a date.
He chickened out.
RACHAEL RAY: Nice.
AUDIENCE: And the second time--
RACHAEL RAY: His loss.
You're stunning.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And then the second
time, we did the potluck.
I don't know if you
remember that show.
It was a potluck, bring--
RACHAEL RAY: Oh,
everybody brought dishes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I--
RACHAEL RAY:
Literally a potluck.
AUDIENCE: --did the
Italian skewers.
RACHAEL RAY: Nice.
AUDIENCE: And that was way
before I decided to be vegan.
I decided to be crazy--
RACHAEL RAY: Hey, man, I
am very into the vegan.
I have broken down every wall.
I used to be like, aw, man,
can't we all just get along
and live in moderation?
I have studied so much,
trying to educate myself
about vegan, vegetarian,
and I'm down with it now.
I really am.
AUDIENCE: Well,
that's my question.
I was going to ask you what's
your favorite vegan dish.
RACHAEL RAY: You
know, it depends.
I write a lot of them
for some of our guests
that are, of course, vegan.
This time of year, my
lentil and beet soup is--
you got to go and
download this immediately.
I wrote it for Alan
Cummings was on the show
and I love him so much.
I'm obsessed with that soup.
It's so easy to make and it's
the perfect time of year.
Beets are so cheap and cheerful
right now and just delicious.
And do you eat pasta?
Do you--
ASIA SEAVERS: Yeah.
RACHAEL RAY: Are
you down with pasta?
So I make a pasta that's
cooked in red wine
with roasted beets
and beet greens.
You want to get into
anybody's anything, make that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHAEL RAY: Just
don't made for people
you don't really, really like,
because they will come back
and you know, that's that.
I also love-- my favorite
restaurant that's vegan,
vegetarian is Nix.
Have you been to Nix?
AUDIENCE: I haven't been.
RACHAEL RAY: I'm going
to change your world.
So Nix is in my neighborhood.
My husband, his favorite word
other than scotch is pork.
My husband loves this restaurant
and we go there once a week,
no problem.
Nix is the name of the
Supreme Court case in America
that allowed produce people
to classify tomatoes, which
are fruits, as vegetables
because they thought
it was better PR.
That's insane.
It's "Nix versus" whatever's
the name of the case.
So Nix, N-I-X is the
name of the restaurant.
It's all vegan, vegetarian
and it is amazing.
They make duck buns that aren't
duck, they're cauliflower.
They make braised
pork shoulder that's
a cabbage that tastes
smoky and crazy.
It is the find of the century.
They make little
shiitake mushroom tacos.
They have insane tandoor
bread with all sorts
of dips and spreads.
Go to Nix, immediately.
And they have one
of the best cocktail
programs in New York City.
You will have the best--
again, only take people you
like there because you'll
have to return with them.
AUDIENCE: Rachael, instead of
Mario, will you be my date?
RACHAEL RAY: Absolutely.
I live in the hood.
Easy.
Done.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Thank you.
RACHAEL RAY: I love that.
Maybe I'll be in page six.
Rachael had a lesbian date.
She was so hot for this girl.
ASIA SEAVERS: Whoop, whoop.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Rachael.
RACHAEL RAY: I would love to
be in somebody's cool gossip
column.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
RACHAEL RAY: So not
the lame, you know,
I cook better than her.
I don't like her.
I want to be
something that's cool.
ASIA SEAVERS: Something juicy.
RACHAEL RAY: Right,
right, right.
ASIA SEAVERS:
Like, I'm in there.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
I'm a big fan of
your show and the--
RACHAEL RAY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --other
projects you work on.
It sounds like there are so many
amazing aspects of your job.
So I was curious what your
favorite part of your job is.
And you're such a
positive person,
I don't know if you'll
be able to answer this,
but if you have a least
favorite part of your job.
RACHAEL RAY: Red
carpet anything. .
AUDIENCE: Least favorite or--
RACHAEL RAY: Least.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh.
RACHAEL RAY: Any time I have
to be on a carpet, surrounded
by what I think are
real celebrities,
I'm sick to my stomach.
I hate super high heels.
When I went to--
I love Michelle
and Barack Obama.
I got to work with
them for the entirety
of their administration.
I miss them.
I considered them
actual friends,
which is mind blowing to me.
But probably the most
embarrassing night of my life
was going to their
last state dinner,
which was for the
prime minister of Italy
and his beautiful wife.
Walking into the White
House, first of all,
I chose a dress that
was very autumnal
because it was late October.
Freaky summer-like
90-plus day, I'm
in a dress with a black
turtleneck up to here.
So a river ran through it.
I'm pouring sweat
the whole night.
And walking up the steps, I'm
not even in the White House
yet, I stick my giant high
heel through the inside lining
of my dress and rip
the entire thing out
and tie the tulle around
my foot so much so--
by the way, I'm getting chills
while I'm telling you this.
The woman at the desk that's
checking in everybody--
everybody, prime ministers,
presidents, movie stars--
she has to leave her
post to go find scissors
to cut my foot out
of the inside lining.
This is before I even walked
the carpet have the picture.
Yeah.
Worst, worst, worst.
Then I get inside and I find
out we're at the head table.
No stress there.
It was like-- I can't.
I'm hive-y just
talking about it.
It's so hard to me.
The thing that makes me
feel most comfortable
is being in our
studio because I know
that whether it's somebody
new who's been there
or somebody that's never been
there, that that's our house
and we play by our
rules and everybody
is going to feel comfortable.
And I feel like I'm in
a really safe place.
I love being at our job.
My most favorite thing
that I do in my entire year
is Feedback, which is a
show I put together 10--
now 11-- years ago at
South by Southwest.
My husband is a lawyer by
day but he has a rock band.
He got into Berklee
School of Music
but his parents wanted
him to be a lawyer
so he wussed out and didn't
just pay for his own schooling
like the rest of the world.
But he saved me a fortune
over the years because he
became an entertainment lawyer,
so that came in quite handy.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
RACHAEL RAY: But we are
both really into music.
We have about 2,500
vinyl records.
The most expensive
thing in our apartment
is our floating record player.
And we have this
combination of my food,
sponsored cocktails, no
overcrowding, three stages,
20 or so bands during
a day long rock concert
that we call Feedback.
And it is the most fun
I have all year long.
It's during the
South by Southwest
music festival in Austin
and that is my Christmas.
And we're doing interesting
things with that.
I have to leave it at that.
But we're doing some
interesting things with that.
AUDIENCE: One
follow-up question,
as a follow record player owner,
what is your favorite record?
"Hunky Dory."
David Bowie is probably
my favorite single artist.
We have an enormous
Beatles collection.
The one that's most special
to both my husband and myself
is our "Sergeant Pepper's"
that's signed by Ringo.
Again, I almost
burst into tears.
Because he did it the
day he was on our show
and he doesn't sign
anything, you know?
And my husband was telling
him that his first word was
more because he had the
"Sergeant Pepper's mono
playing on his little
toddler record player.
And his mom wanted him
to come to the table
and sit in his high chair and
eat dinner with the family.
And she took the record
off and he got so mad
he screamed, more, and
that's his first word
and he ripped the cover.
And Ringo made fun
of him and said,
you know, I could have brought
you a fresh one of this
and he signed it for him.
But the idea that it's
John's first word,
that I ever got to
meet a Beatle, I mean,
it makes me want to
burst into tears.
My first word was vino,
no big surprise there.
[LAUGHTER]
My Grandpa made wine and
he used to babysit me
when I was little because
my mom was in the restaurant
and I hated formula.
My mom raised me on formula.
So he used to put
water and a little
of his homemade
wine and my bottle
and he'd hold the bottle
up and go, vino, vino.
And I would drink that and
then my cheeks would get rosy
and I'd go to sleep.
So I was the good baby, right?
But he would hold up my
bottle and I thought,
that's how you said
ba-ba was vino.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh, no.
RACHAEL RAY: There's
a picture of me
in one of those stick the high
chair on the edge of the table.
They stopped selling
them because they
killed so many people.
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh.
RACHAEL RAY: But I'm in one
of those hook on high chairs.
It's an old Polaroid
and on the back
it says, Rachael's
first word, vino.
And it's me holding my
hand up from my ba-ba,
but it looks like
I'm a drunk at a bar.
So funny.
So my husband, more, mine, vino.
More vino.
That's we got married in
Tuscany in a vineyard.
ASIA SEAVERS: That
makes so much sense.
Oh, my god.
Mind blown.
RACHAEL RAY: Anyway, that
was a great question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming in today.
Really cool way
to start the week.
RACHAEL RAY: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
hosting my first
ever Thanksgiving this
year for around 25 people,
and I was wondering
if you had advice on--
RACHAEL RAY: I have lots.
AUDIENCE: Oh, great.
I was onto the side dish
that you would recommend
and any general advice
would be awesome.
RACHAEL RAY: For the
turkeys themselves,
you're doing the whole thing?
AUDIENCE: I'm outsourcing
the turkey to my parents
but I'm going to do the rest.
RACHAEL RAY: See, now
I wouldn't do that.
The turkey is the easiest.
But let me tell you
my top turkey tips
in case you're brave enough to
do the actual birds next time.
It's a funny term.
It's an old English term.
Spatchcocking is when you take
the backbone out of any poultry
and make it flat.
And I never make one big bird.
It's impossible to successfully
cook one large bird
and you should do
a pound per person,
so that'd be a 25-pound bird.
That's a big bird.
So we spatchcocked the
birds for even cooking.
So the white meat
in the dark meat
cooked at the exact same time.
And always, no matter how
many people I'm cooking for,
I do birds there
are 12 to 14 pounds
and then multiples of them.
So you do two birds is what I
would recommend for you guys,
flattened, on a rock.
It cuts your cooking
time down to a third.
It cooks perfectly
evenly and you
can platter one on a
giant cutting board
and carve the other
one completely
before you even sit down.
So there's one you can
decorate and it stays pretty
till everybody's
seated at least.
Side dishes, we have
millions on the website
and of course on the show site.
We have literally
over a decade of them.
But I think generally
speaking, roast vegetables
are very simple for people.
Cauliflower, whole
heads of cauliflower
are very showy and
very simple to master.
We have tons of
recipes for them.
They look like
giant brains and you
can do like three giant
whole roast cauliflowers
and you cut them like cake
and it looks really fancy.
You can pour Welsh
rarebit sauce over them
or lots of ricotta
and parmigiano
and garlic all over them.
And it just looks cool.
Roast vegetables are
your easiest bet.
Mashed potatoes hold
all day in a bain-marie
and you can make those
interesting by doing
a third of the weight
in parsnip, which is
like a carrot with an attitude.
Parsnip and potato
together and then mixing
in a surprising flavor, boursin
soft cheese and garlic and herb
or super sharp cheddar and
nutmeg and a little cayenne
pepper.
That's always a big hit.
People love the mashed potatoes.
I rarely make gravy
out of the pan stock.
I'll add a little bit but I
always make gallons of gravy.
And I do that with store
bought turkey stock.
And the way I deepen the flavor
of my gravy and the color
is with Worcestershire sauce
rather than that gravy liquid
stuff.
On and on and on.
Baked pastas are always
popular with people.
Pumpkin soup is such
an easy starter.
Deviled eggs, people love.
I always do stuffed eggs
to start the course.
Everybody loves them
and they're so easy.
But honestly, I got
you covered on this.
Go to our web sites and just
put in Thanksgiving sides.
You'll be able to
download a ream--
like 500-- recipes.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
And maybe I'll give
the turkey a try.
RACHAEL RAY: OK, good.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Rachael.
Thanks again for being here.
RACHAEL RAY: Thanks
for having me
AUDIENCE: I have a bit
of a silly question
but I'm really curious.
RACHAEL RAY: I'm a silly
person, so that's--
AUDIENCE: Great.
So when Beyonce's "Lemonade"
came out, there were some--
RACHAEL RAY: Oh, I was
in bad news once, right?
The most preposterous thing
in the world, that I even
know Jay Z is ridiculous.
ASIA SEAVERS: Right.
Oh, no.
RACHAEL RAY: But anyway, I
barely had an awareness of it
until I went to
work the next day.
And all of the young people that
worked for me told me about it.
But I just thought
it was hilarious.
And I was kind of thrilled.
I sent Rachel Roy some flowers
and apologized to her, though.
AUDIENCE: Does everybody
know what I'm referring to?
Maybe you want to tell
them what happened.
RACHAEL RAY: No, you
can go right ahead.
Somehow, it was rumored
that Rachel Roy,
the super tall, gorgeous
fashion designer lady
got mixed up with
me, Rachael Ray,
and that they were rumored
to have been having
a fling, Jay Z and her, not me.
So somehow, I got into
this and all these people
were zapping me with their
stingers or something,
all hating on me.
I'm like, I think that's really
flattering that anybody even
thinks I'm in that room.
I'm home in my King Kong
slippers making John spaghetti.
The idea that I could even be
in the room with those people.
Come on.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Which leads me to
the second half of my question.
It's how much were
you aware of what--
RACHAEL RAY: Not at all.
AUDIENCE: --on social media.
RACHAEL RAY: Zero.
Zippo.
Zilch-o.
But thank you for reminding
me that one time I
was by accident cool.
[LAUGHTER]
Cool enough to be
gossiped about.
Yeah.
I was cool enough to be in
the room once by mistake.
[LAUGHS]
ASIA SEAVERS: That's perfect.
That was funny.
RACHAEL RAY: Hi.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Rachael, so with
the past 10 or 15 years,
we've seen people care
more about local food,
organic food--
RACHAEL RAY: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: --and natural stuff.
So what other trends
do you see going
into the future, or some new
things people are trying?
RACHAEL RAY: I think it goes
back to that awareness thing,
just that everybody's having
the conversation about it.
What I hope people do is take
it to the local government
and grassroots level.
Unfortunately, a lot of
the work that I put in
over the last eight years,
lobbying literally physically
in person in Washington and
improving the quality of school
food has just been ripped out.
Although Mayor de
Blasio in New York City,
I'm so proud to say,
as of last Thursday,
no more food shaming in
the city of New York.
Every child now has equal access
to school lunch in New York,
which is amazing and
that's a huge thing.
What I would love
people to not only--
[APPLAUSE]
I agree.
It's a very, very,
very big deal.
But I would love to see people
take what they like about food
or what they've learned about
it and share with younger people
and people in their
community and care
about the quality of food
of their neighbors, not just
themselves.
I think that everybody now
has the knowledge to do that
and when you see
natural disasters,
understand that there
is always a disaster,
whether you live in a
small town or a big city.
There's a food bank
everywhere that you
should be giving of your time
and your money or both or food
to those around you and
educating each other,
talking to each other about it.
Because we have to
build that network.
I don't even have
human children.
I have a pit bull.
But I care about the quality
of school food and access
to food because I care
about health care costs,
because I care about the
ability of children to learn,
because they're going to grow up
and become the next generation
of everything for us.
I need them to be
healthy and smart.
So I'm hoping that
what comes out
of everybody getting more social
and sharing with each other
and coming up with all these
alternatives for no matter
what type of lifestyle you
want to live that they also
take the time to share
that with each other
and be mindful of giving
back to their community.
I think the last
hurdle for young people
is because of social media,
everybody is also very vision.
We don't socialize in
person as much as we should.
We don't spend as much time
in the community as we should.
I think that we need
to be mindful of that,
not to be so closed-in
and only communicating
with each other like this.
To go out and spend
time with actual people
and share with them
I think is important.
What I'd like people to do
with food and anything else
that they have to offer is
to be more community-minded.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ASIA SEAVERS: Any
more questions?
RACHAEL RAY: Wow,
that was serious.
[LAUGHTER]
ASIA SEAVERS: Do we have
any other questions?
No?
RACHAEL RAY: All right,
think we can all just
do the staring contest.
ASIA SEAVERS: We can but
we're actually on time.
RACHAEL RAY: Oh,
we're on time, yay!
ASIA SEAVERS:
Whoop, whoop, whoop.
RACHAEL RAY: Woo!
ASIA SEAVERS: Oh, yeah.
So thank you so much, Rachael.
Let's give a hand for Rachael.
RACHAEL RAY: Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
I hope that was fun for you.
ASIA SEAVERS: It was.
I had so much fun.
RACHAEL RAY:
Certainly fun for me.
Today's my mother
in law's birthday.
That's rough, of course,
to have your birthday
on a very somber occasion.
But it's our family
business tonight
to go out and make her feel
special for a few hours.
ASIA SEAVERS: OK.
RACHAEL RAY: So I'm going
to go do exactly what she'd
want me to do and have a
glass of wine before dinner
and get myself in the mood.
Thanks, everybody.
I really appreciate being here.
Thank you.
ASIA SEAVERS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHAEL RAY: Thanks, AJ.
ASIA SEAVERS: No,
thank you, Rachael.
RACHAEL RAY: You're such a
cutie pie and I love that--